house Intel Chairman Adam Schiff
repeatedly went out of his way to claim
that Trump not just right
Trump colluded with Russia even when he
had zero evidence of it now the White
House is calling for his resignation
joining me now
assistant to the president White House
director of strategic comms Mercedes
schlepp Mercedes ship isn't gonna go
isn't gonna resign and Congress from an
clabe tonight told the Democrats she has
a lot of juice now a lot of power with
tape says do not give up on impeachment
what say you
well I think that the Democrats ultimate
goal isn't Pietschmann I actually think
it makes Nancy Pelosi nervous because
she is saying well we might not want to
go there we need a bipartisan effort to
move towards impeachment but for the
Democrats from day one their goal and
they run on trying to impeach the
president and so I think the American
people clearly see through this I think
we know that the Democrats have gone way
too far
they've been reckless in this process
they have been irresponsible in terms of
for two years spending hour after hour
after hour making this building this
narrative building this case that the
president had with the Russians and
Muller report obviously as we know the
president's now fully exonerate I want
to put up a couple of graphs from the
letter from bar which I think are
important let's put up the first one
okay Deputy Attorney General Rosenstein
and I concluded that the evidence
developed during the special counsels
investigation is not sufficient to
establish the president committed an
obstruction of justice offense Special
Counsel recognize that the evidence does
not establish that the president was
involved in an underlying crime that's
related to Russian election interference
and that while not determinative the
absence of such evidence bears upon the
president's intent with respect to
obstruction what does that mean there's
no underlying crime so the president
everything he did was out in the open it
was like he's frustrated he's mad I mean
imagine if you're accused of something
basically treason that's right and all
these people are against you I'd be
really mad too in fact they did accuse
me of various things the Russians I'm
like are you kidding me but here the
president knighted States he was really
mad so that was supposed to be
obstruction and in Muller tried to
interview the president I guess and they
couldn't get anyone DOJ to to think that
that was going
be a good idea you don't have the
evidence of any crime to interview the
President or subpoena the president they
had no evidence of any intent to
obstruct justice period that's clear
here it's very clear and I think that
this is like the brilliance of the
president's president which is that that
he's resilient despite the fact of all
the pressure of this investigation
despite the fact that it's been over
8,500 articles written story aired in
CNN New York Times Washington Post and
MSNBC what we've known is that this
president has been in high gear he has
stayed focused on the economy on the
trade deals on securing the border and
keeps fighting every day for the
American people our people and I have to
say it's it really shows that the
Democrats they've made a big gamble with
this and that they lost because they've
made they thought this mullah report was
gonna be their way to hurt the country
let's talk about what happened to the
country they divided this country they
made politics even more toxic it did
frustrate the president I can't blame
him for being frustrated he's trying to
make good deals for the country maybe we
work with Russia on some things we don't
on others because they really bug us on
other things but all of this had the
taint of this investigation hanging over
now he's free of that I agree but think
about how much they tried to destroy
this he's right only I think only only
this oh my god would have just like wet
themselves this is like guys I'm sorry
so many other Republicans something that
is so great about this man is that he
fights and he was not gonna give us a
lesson they the Democrats are fighting
stood the Republicans have got to fight
for this President's agenda Mercedes
they have to gotta fight for the
President's agenda it's the right agenda
I mean it's clear that based on his
accomplishments alone when you're
looking at this booming economy
impacting so many communities the fact
that he's standing tough on China and
God we gotta support him on that and by
the way what would you agree with the
reckoning there has to be a reckoning
there it I really feel that there needs
to be accountability I mean this has
been irresponsible reporting it's
journalism at a point that we've lost
they've lost their way what about your
objective what about the people at DOJ I
mean I think one of the things that
we've learned is that there's those
elements and the FBI as we've seen with
Andrew McCabe that is has
he's been under investigation he lied
under oath that helped create and
ferment this horrific situation that
we've seen and at the end of the day the
president has been exonerated you know
yesterday basically said there's
basically still evidence of collusion oh
they all their bait Oh Kamala Harris
exactly to them this is they they really
want to continue campaigning for the
truthers right there they want to
campaign on this collusion they want to
keep bringing doubts in the minds of the
American people
Mulla report is very clear the president
has been completely exonerated and we're
moving ahead with the agenda the
Democrats can continue playing these
politics but at this moment in time I
think the American people want to see
solutions and that's what the
president's working on results for the
American people with the roads got to
hit the road and sell this agenda go to
blue state America sell this agenda
thank you for being here tonight we did
not quit this is not collusion on
outfits okay different shape